Випадковість чи провокація?
Уперше після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну російський літак
зіткнувся з американським безпілотником.
Один із пари російських винищувачів Су-27 врізався в розвідувальний дрон США MQ-9 "Reaper"
над акваторією Чорного моря.
Уже були схожі інциденти з британськими розвідувальними літаками теж над Чорним морем,
що призвело до призупинення розвідувальних місій британських літаків.
Але вперше сталося зіткнення в повітрі, що робить інцидент небезпечним з точки зору ескалації.
Російські пілоти повелися значно агресивніше, ніж зазвичай.
Взаємні перехоплення й супроводження літаків - це звична практика вже протягом багатьох років.
Такі перехоплення трапляються. Але це відрізняється своєю агресивністю.
У Пентагоні роз'яснили деталі: російські небезпечно маневрували перед дроном
і скидали пальне, намагаючись погіршити видимість для безпілотника або пошкодити його.
Водночас у американського оборонного відомства поки немає даних про те,
що росіянам вдалося знайти збитий безпілотник.
Ми ще вивчаємо те, що сталося.
Але, виходячи з дій російських пілотів, очевидно, що вони діяли небезпечно і непрофесійно.
Думаю, результат говорить сам за себе.
Ми бачили, що винищувач скидав авіапальне перед безпілотником,
а потім підійшов так близько, що пошкодив гвинт MQ-9.
За нашими оцінками, унаслідок цього російський винищувач теж зазнав пошкоджень.
Російське міноборони заявило, що їхні винищувачі не причетні до падіння дрона.
А посол РФ у Штатах, якого викликали в Держдепартамент, заявив, що вважає інцидент провокацією.
Не було контакту, не було використання ніякого озброєння нашими винищувачами.
І цей безпілотний літальний апарат, виконавши різкий розворот, врізався в простір.
Апарат летів з вимкненими транспондерами і він увійшов у зону,
яку було визначено як зону спеціальної військової операції.
За міжнародними каналами ми - Росія, попередили всіх про це. Я вважаю, що це справжня провокація.
Провокацією, але з російського боку вважає інцидент експерт з питань безпеки Том Карако.
Усе напевне виглядає так, ніби російський пілот крутився навколо дрона
й навмисно намагався знищити, як заявляється, американський безпілотник MQ 9 над Чорним морем.
Отже, це провокація. Щось схоже на тест.
Росіянам, звісно, не подобається, що ми літаємо над міжнародними водами,
і вони цілком очевидно висловлюють своє невдоволення.
Натомість британський фахівець Майк Мартін не певен,
що росіяни навмисне атакували американський дрон.
Для Росії звична справа супроводжувати розвідувальні літальні апарати,
вони роблять це і щодо британських літаків над Північним морем.
Не думаю, що росіяни хотіли збити американський безпілотник.
Радше через залякування і супроводження на близькій відстані стався прорахунок
і американський літак довелося приводнити.
Лідер демократичної більшості в американському Сенаті Чак Шумер наголосив,
що Сполучені Штати регулярно здійснюють польоти над Чорним морем і робитимуть це надалі.
Сенатор застеріг російську сторону від ескалації.
Це ще один безрозсудний вчинок президента Путіна та його військових.
Я хочу сказати пану Путіну: припиніть таку поведінку,
перш ніж ви станете причиною ненавмисної ескалації.
Ми бачили таку поведінку російських військових раніше,
і це не стримає Сполучені Штати від проведення операцій над Чорним морем.
Ці агресивні дії російської авіації є ризикованими і можуть призвести, повторюю, до ненавмисної ескалації.
Раніше американські дрони моніторили лінію розмежування на Донбасі.
Нині безпілотники США практично щодня літають над Чорним морем, зазначили в українських Повітряних силах.
З лютого 2022 року розвідувальна інформація, яку збирають такі літальні апарати,
стала особливо цінною для українських військових.
У будь-який момент часу від шести до десяти літальних апаратів НАТО
перебувають у повітряному просторі сусідніх з Україною держав.
Вони всі зв'язуються між собою, прослуховують російські комунікації.
Ця інформація збирається, аналізується і передається українським військовим,
аби вони могли ефективно відпрацьовувати цілі.
Якщо пам'ятаєте, на початку війни Росія втратила 20-30 генералів у короткий період часу.
Усе завдяки ось таким діям.
Те, що росіяни втрачають менше генералів зараз означає,
що вони зробили свої системи комунікацій більш захищеними.
MQ 9 Reaper - один із найпоширеніших дронів.
Він може нести ракети, але той, що впав у Чорне море, як повідомили в Пентагоні,
займався саме розвідкою і спостереженням над міжнародними водами.
На жаль, росіяни вважають Чорне море своїм озером.
З юридичної точки зору, це міжнародні води.
Росії може не подобатися цей факт,
але з точки зору міжнародного права, це захищає Сполучені Штати від будь-яких звинувачень
у порушенні російського повітряного простору.
Ключове питання: чи призведе інцидент у Чорному морі до ескалації між США і Росією?
І Кремль, і Вашингтон не раз демонстрували, що не бажають прямого зіткнення.
Через це аналітики американського інституту вивчення війни вважають,
що причин для "небезпечної ескалації" немає.
Такої думки дотримуються й опитані DW експерти.
Складно уявити більшу ескалацію в цій війні і ще гірші відносини Росії і США, ніж вони є нині.
Як ми бачимо, зокрема, зі слів російського посла,
обидві сторони нароблять чимало галасу з приводу цієї ситуації,
утім вони все ж прагнуть переступити через цей епізод і рухатися далі.
Попри їхню риторику, росіянам, думаю, варто заспокоїтися
і припинити агресивні перехоплення над Чорним морем у міжнародному повітряному просторі,
аби не було ескалації.
Особливо, якщо це буде стосуватися пілотованих літальних апаратів.
Ось тут є можливості для ескалації, про яку варто непокоїтися.
Тим часом невдовзі після інциденту в Чорному морі німецькі й британські винищувачі
перехопили російський Іл-78, а потім і Ан-148 неподалік повітряного простору Естонії.
Уперше таку операцію спільно провели повітряні сили двох держав НАТО.